an alternative for this and this
particularly worked well if you're going
away on holiday again I don't want to
come across as the transactional sex guy
but if you need to try and find yourself
some companionship what about our
Constitution guy and if you need to find
yourself some companionship while you're
going away I think this is not too much
strategy so uncertain des needs to pay
for tinder gold then you need to be able
to move your location to where it is
that you're gonna go pop yourself into
there determine your range tighten the
range in so that you are well within
taxi distance of wherever it is that
you're stinks you don't like you're not
gonna travel to the other side of God
knows what then as you swiping through
people if there's someone that you find
that you particularly like you can in
scroll down got their Instagram click
through one to their Instagram so it
opens DM them sent message then go back
on a tinder swipe left so that they
never see you and never find out that
you've found them on tinder then
continue the exchange on Instagram now
obviously what all of this that
particular exchange is dependent on is
the fact that you have an Instagram
which at least shows some form of value
and that works for both guys and girls
like it if you even if not you still
will come across as less of a creep
having an Instagram profile and evidence
of friends or evidence so absolutely you
know you're immediately rated above the
best person on to the worst person
Instagram is rated above the best person
on tinder so we've got in this so I've
been through that I've done that with
tip with tinder I've got five or six
people on Instagram there's two problems
now one is if my Instagram just photos
of me like no then I'll probably
struggle but also I have to say the
right things to them so this is a wash
your mind surround feet look like so I
said this on the how we get them loved
island video and it's that your
Instagram particularly because it's
quite surface deep quite transactional
very easy to seat visual right like
Twitter and Facebook is a little bit
more nuanced because it's microblogging
whereas when you're looking at Instagram
it's like window shoppers just images
right yeah exactly so Instagram is
absolutely no representation of your
value but it is a ubiquitous
internationally recognized
form of social currency and it does
represent some degree of popularity
people do need to think about the way
that they come across online let as well
you might be someone from the old school
who says I prefer to meet people the old
way it's that well that's great but you
have to spend an awful lot of time out
and about just in looking versus how
efficient you can be on your phone
especially the fact that you can
essentially be dating this is presuming
again presuming that somebody actually
wants to find a partner and you can be
dating on your lunch break
I mean browsing around messaging people
and putting in groundwork so to speak so
that you you know progressed whatever
relationship is there to the 90s where
you don't you go out to a coffee shop
and just speak to people on your lunch
break well I mean it's like that's if it
the the interesting thing as well just
on the note of like the image that
you're creating on Instagram is what you
said about like if there's multiple
photos of them just play because I think
there is no greater creep stamp than
photos of someone in the house on the
road because it's just like or a series
of photos of one person in lots of
different locations yeah you see some
people that all of that profile these
seasonal Facebook like people their
profile photos they've got ten and it's
always just them either in their room or
in different places
slightly sullen slightly yes and a happy
it like a magazine isn't it or a
brochure of you but again like this is
you know if someone can say well that
you know [ __ ] now I'm not using my
Instagram as a shop window for me like
that's fine but you need to concede that
if Instagram was part of your lead
generation they usually which is what
which it can be like again good dancer
fine you don't need to do Instagram you
can do whatever but if you want to give
yourself obviously you know eighty
twenty eight cover all of the bases to a
degree and it's not hard to have a good
outward representation of you so so yeah
like the photos of you pushing your mate
down the street in a trolley pissed or
like you battered at your grandma's 80th
like that probably keep them off and
stick to the ones that are well lit and
okay look nice so my main point here in
the whole thing really about the
Instagram the Instagram funnel is just
that you want to have
some form of high immediate value that
other people can interpret and I think
the reason that instagram has become
this really interesting social currency
is that it is a game that almost
everybody's playing so - the same as
when you watch the Olympics you watch
Usain Bolt and you watch how fast he
runs everybody has run pretty much
everybody is wrong and you're like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] I've done something similar
to that and he is the best in the world
at it so because I have an Instagram
yeah and I have 400 followers and I see
someone's Instagram that has 5,000
followers and lots of really polished
photos and say wow this person good
shopping - therefore is popular but
you've got say so it's so everything
yeah right and this comes back to can if
the first thing that said which i think
is really virtuous actually that a lot
of people would make fantastic potential
partners the only problem is that you're
not giving them the chance it's the
marketing yeah
they're literally the Latorre just
marketing themselves poorly or maybe
you're marketing yourself poorly so it's
like right well if you present yourself
online in the best possible way and if
everyone else does as well then you're
giving yourself the best chance of being
accepted by whoever to whichever
potential partners it is that you want
to get suppose all Tinder's doing by
allowing photos and content on there is
a is a almost like a template if I look
fill this in fill it fill the best stuff
in and this is a mini version of
Instagram isn't it and everyone has that
but that's all in the context of I've
created this to try and get day or get
lady - well there's the least sexy thing
about any exchange between two single
people is one of them obviously knowing
that the other ones after them mmm and
tinder precludes that immediately yeah
does that make sense like you just chops
off at the knees any coyness about the
exchange cuz I have the [ __ ] would
like you we both know why we're on here
which is good for the very utilitarian
like
I've got time for any nonsense but
anyway they're just like right okay I
get that hair often even with that in
the exchange it's backwards and forwards
that you have on tinder they tend to be
so like vapid that's why everyone's just
like you see the whole arm just on here
as a joke like oh you're just not really
serious like people trying to qualify
that they're not really that serious
about it and to try and communicate that
in short tinder should only be used for
li chen get them on instagram then use
that for lead conversion okay there we
go
and when it comes to that
[Music]
you